[Musique]
et on va évidemment continuer à parler
des élections de mi-mandat aux
États-Unis on part ce soir en
Pennsylvanie Anthonie c'est l'un des
états clés qui pourraient faire basculer
la majorité au Sénat du côté républicain
ou du côté démocrates et des accusations
de fraude ont visé l'état de l'Est
américain effectivement plusieurs
internautes là sur il y a eu fraude il y
a eu tricherie en témoigne par exemple
ce commentaire d'un utilisateur de
Instagram avec un nom plus qu'évocateur
ultra Maga mais que mamerica great again
le slogan il y a quelques années
maintenant en deux Donald Trump et cette
internaute de nous dire rien de tel que
des élections libres et équitables que
des boîtes à vote près chargées alors
cette internaute qui à côté de son
commentaire à publier l'en-tête d'un
article que l'on voit ici d'un site pas
n'importe lequel get tway upendit qui
est un site d'information de l'extrême
droite américaine connue pour ses propos
mensongers pour ces théories du complot
pour aussi valider la thèse que
l'élection de 2020 a été volée à Donald
Trump cet article on le retrouve ici il
a été publié le 27 octobre dernier donc
et à l'intérieur de certains articles
vous voyez il y a une vidéo qui sert de
preuve aux accusateurs donc de tricherie
vidéo que l'on va découvrir ensemble et
que l'on voit ici donc on va avancer un
petit peu pour aller un petit peu plus
vite on voit sur cette vidéo un
fonctionnaire qui est chargé donc de la
mise en place de l'organisation de ces
élections et sur cette vidéo vous voyez
qu'il ouvre une boîte à vote pour y
déposer un sac officiel pour pouvoir
récolter les bulletins le jour du vote
donc sauf que à sa grande surprise il y
a déjà un débutant une dizaine en
l'occurrence dans cette
urne une vidéo qui me porte la mention
et c'est important de Rumble plateforme
de l'ultra-droite américaine et cette
vidéo est-ce qu'elle est authentique et
bien oui elle est tout à fait
authentique cette vidéo il y a eu
irrégularité pas fraude explication les
responsables électoraux du comté en
question ont expliqué que les électeurs
qui avaient donc glissé ces bulletins
n'avaient tout simplement pas respecter
les consignes de vote qui leur avait été
envoyés quelques jours auparavant en
l'occurrence de ne pas voter avant le 25
octobre date de la mise à disposition si
je puis dire de cette boîte à vote à
cela s'ajoute toutefois un défaut de la
boîte en question qui jamais n'aurait dû
permettre l'accès aux électeurs de
pouvoir donc déposer leur bulletin dans
l'urne à cette date du 25 octobre mais
les responsables de préciser aussi que
une fois que vous aviez glissé le
bulletin dans l'urne il était impossible
de le récupérer que le contenu ne
pouvait pas donc être accessible malgré
ce défaut à moins bien sûr d'être un
fonctionnaire et d'avoir la clé pour y
accéder donc irrégularité oui pas fraude
défaut qui a été évidemment corrigé par
la suite incident toutefois qui a eu
lieu dans ce comté à trois reprises au
total là c'était une dizaine de votes au
total ce sont 18 bulletins qui ont été
concernés des votes validés
comptabilisés une fois que l'identité
des électeurs a été validé merci
beaucoup pour cette éclairage Anthony
sans léger vous restez avec nous au
marque une courte pause et on se
retrouve tout de suite pour un nouveau
journal
[Musique]